c'est ici sous ces tentes que l'arrêt
des affrontements s'est décidée vers
22h30 hier soir après quatre jours de
forte tension des représentants de la
communauté tchétchène et maghrébine se
réunissent dans cette mosquée de
quétigny à proximité de dijon
l'imam mohamed à thèbes se félicite de
ces discussions nous ont dit voilà veut
dire que pour eux ce n'est pas une
affaire communautaire et non lien il ne
vise pas une communauté particulière et
que voilà que l'incident même fait dix
de leurs enfants ce n'est qu'il est
définitivement clos et qu'il appelle à
la place cet imam n'est pas le seul à
appeler au calme
le point de départ de ces tensions se
serait l'agression d'un jeune tchétchène
la semaine dernière son père veut aussi
l'apaisement
on est venu en france pour notre
sécurité or au vivre dans un pays normal
on perd en calme mais pas de guerre pas
de rien mais ces derniers seront ils
écoutés
va-t-on revoir ces scènes comme ici en
plein centre-ville de dijon ou encore là
dans le quartier des grésillés cette
nuit en tout cas aucun incident n'était
à déplorer
pas de voitures incendiées pas
d'affrontement et une forte présence
policière
pour ce responsable syndical la
situation est sous contrôle mais il veut
rester prudent on n'a pas de boule de
cristal
nous on fait en sorte que ça se s'arrête
que ça s'apaise de rapidement voilà
rapidement faire ce qui doit être fait
pour que la situation s'arrête et
reviennent à la normale
on met tous les moyens de la disposition
par contre là vous dire que ça repartira
pas ça c'est une affirmation que je peux
pas faire c'est tout ce qu'on souhaite
dans le quartier des grésillés
le calme est revenu ce matin pour les
événements de ces derniers jours les
investigations se poursuivent
quatre personnes ont été entendues par
les enquêteurs